que je vous remercie chers collègues
d'être ici présent madame la rapporteur
donc Mesdames et Messieurs notre
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française poursuit
aujourd'hui c'est ces travaux par
l'audition conjointe de plusieurs
associations d'usagers de professionnels
du système de santé dont la voix est
évidemment
déterminante pour notre analyse de ce
problème nous avons déjà effectué une
première table ronde de ce type qui a
été très instructive il nous est
particulièrement précieux en effet de
bénéficier de votre expérience et de vos
témoignages sur la façon dont ces
tensions et ruptures d'approvisionnement
qui dessine une situation chronique
désormais je pense que au bout de au
moins une quinzaine d'années on peut le
dire pèse très concrètement sur la vie
des patients et des soignants chaque
occurrence de pénurie alterne la qualité
des soins suscite angoisse et détresse
légitimes chez les patients et leurs
proches des organisations incertitudes
et perte de temps médical pour l'équipe
so et peut même engendrer et vous nous
direz jusqu'à quel point des pertes de
chances qui ne sont jamais acceptables
voir
[Musique]
des arrêts même de traitement sont
présents autour de la table donc Madame
Catherine Simonin pour France assassault
santé l'Union nationale les associations
elle est pas autour de la table elle est
en distancielle en visio bonjour madame
l'Union
nationale des associations agréés du
système de santé organisation donc
inter-associative de référence créée en
mars 2017 en remplacement du collectif
inter associatif sur la santé que nous
avons tous bien connu
regroupant près d'une centaine
d'associations France à 60 et
interlocuteur incontournable des
pouvoirs publics et des établissements
de santé et acteurs essentiel de la
démocratie sanitaire représentée défend
les usagers du système de santé
notamment sur les questions de l'accès
aux soins et aux thérapies innovantes
elle donne l'alerte depuis plusieurs
années sur la multiplication des
pénuries de médicaments et ses
conséquences sur la santé des patients
vous aviez d'ailleurs été auditionnés en
juillet 2018 vite lors de la mission du
Sénat sénatorial concernant la pénurie
de médicaments les deux vaccins madame
Juliana verras donc qui est là
coordinatrice de Médecin du Monde ONG
bien connu et qui milite notamment pour
la remise en cause des brevets plus
généralement du modèle économique des
grands laboratoires ceux-ci ont tendance
expliquez-vous à délaisser les molécules
anciennes les produits matures comme on
dit médicament mature moins rentables
quoi qu'indispensable au profit
d'innovation qui n'en sont pas toujours
et qu'elles font payer au prix très fort
tout en se désengageant de la recherche
vous avez notamment obtenu à l'automne
dernier un affaiblissement définitif du
brevet protégeant le sofos buvir la
molécule de gilet indiquée pour contre
l'hépatite C l'Office Européen des
projets des brevets ayant conforté à
l'automne dernier son jugement de
première instance
c'est un élément très important le
docteur Julie
almansourieu vous représentez le
collectif santé en danger créé par le
médecin Arnaud fish en juillet 2020 en
réaction à l'annonce des conclusions du
Ségur de la santé votre association qui
crée qui compte près de 6000 adhérents
et 250
000 abonnés sur les réseaux sociaux
dresse le constat d'un effondrement du
système de santé vous le relayez la
parole et les demandes de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé du privé comme
du public et revendiquer dans la matière
un rôle d'alerte et de vigie
sur le sujet des pénuries médicaments le
collectif a notamment publié le 30
décembre 2022 un communiqué de presse
intitulé la France pays en voie de
régression point d'interrogation vous
nous direz quelle était la valeur de ce
point d'interrogation et s'il s'agissait
selon vous d'une question rhétorique
je pense que non le docteur France
prouet Franck prouet excusez moi médecin
généraliste vous animez le collectif
brevet sur les vaccins stop réquisition
qui faisait partie de la coordination
européenne sur l'initiative citoyenne
européenne pas de profit sur la pandémie
dans ce cas vous militez pour la levée
des brevets sur les vaccins et
traitement anticoïdes et plus récemment
pour la réquisition des moyens de
production de médicaments d'intérêts
majeurs frappés par les pénuries vous
nous direz à quel point les
enseignements que l'on peut tirer de
l'épisode des vaccins anticoïdes qui a
quand même été très instructif peuvent
être transposés aux problèmes de
l'organisation de la production des
médicaments en général et enfin Monsieur
Christophe Duguet vous représentez
l'Association Française contre les
Myopathies la FM Téléthon acteurs
majeur de la lutte contre les maladies
rares vous êtes donc particulièrement
bien placé pour évoquer notamment les
questions de prix et d'accès à
l'innovation thérapeutique je note en
particulier que l'AFM Téléthon a créé
avec BPI France en 2016 la plateforme
industrielle y pose quasi dédiée à la
production sur le sol français de
médicaments de thérapie génique et
cellulaire qui est passé en mars 2021
sous pavillon sud-coréen et c'était là
le destin de bien des initiatives
industrielles pas que sud-coréen mais de
quitter le sol de notre pays à cet égard
votre témoignage peut nous éclairer sur
les enjeux de souveraineté sanitaires et
sur la faisabilité de la création d'une
filière industrielle nationale des
thérapies innovantes
vous le voyez les sujets sont nombreux
et beaucoup de questions restent
pendantes nous sommes rendus au bout
d'un mois d'audition donc on compte
rendre notre rapport de la commission
d'enquête début juillet donc on a encore
voilà un peu de temps devant nous pour
pour vraiment avancer sur tous les
sujets nous vous remercions donc tout
particulièrement mesdames messieurs de
vous être mobilisés aujourd'hui pour
cette audition je vais vous sac CD à
chacun tour à tour la parole pour un
propos introductif d'environ 5 minutes
et les 5 minutes sont importantes parce
que vous êtes nombreux et qu'il faut
qu'on puisse avoir des échanges avec les
collègues ici présents et avec Madame la
rapporteur qui a un certain nombre de
questions à vous poser et moi aussi à
l'occasion puis madame Laurence Cohen
rapporterait de notre commission dans
lequel vous poserez une première série
de questions je précise que nous
adresserons à l'issue de l'audition un
questionnaire complet auquel nous vous
demanderons de répondre par écrit avant
le 15 avril
je précise également que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat avec en plus un bruit
de fond qui doit être assez passionnant
elle fera l'objet d'un compte rendu
publié avant de vous donner la parole je
dois vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête et
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434 13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je vous
invite chacun
votre à votre tour à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant je
le jure madame Simonin
je le jure madame feras
madame allemand souriez
et Monsieur Duguet
très bien je vous remercie et je vous
laisse intervenir donc dans l'ordre
d'interpellation madame Simonin en
premier et puis après on voilà madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs donc je vais donc d'abord
faire les constats les constats
associatifs dans l'observatoire qui
vient d'être publié au niveau de France
à société 37% des personnes ont déjà été
confrontés à une pénurie en 2023
il s'est il était que 25% en 2018
45% des personnes confrontées à ces
pénuries ont été contraintes de reporter
leur traitement de le modifier voir d'y
renoncer ou de l'arrêter c'est l'enquête
de 2020 de la Ligue nationale contre le
cancer je précise également que je suis
administratrice de cette association
68% des oncologues médicaux considèrent
que ces pénuries ont un considéré en
2020 que ces pénuries auront un impact
sur la survie des personnes malades à 5
ans
alors sur le contexte des prix France à
santé comme vous l'avez rappelé ce
mobilise pour donner un accès équitable
aux innovations et de de
challenge qui est posé c'est la
soutenabilité de notre assurance maladie
solidaire
les personnes malades sont désormais
face à un nouveau chantage industriel
augmenter le prix des médicaments
anciens qui je le rappelle non plus de
brevet et pose la question de cette
demande aujourd'hui
alors devons-nous clairement accepter
ces demandes d'augmentation de prix
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons
connaissance que du prix facial des
médicaments c'est à dire des prix
affichés et que derrière ce négocie au
CEPS des remises qui restent non publiés
et qui en cela nous nous ne pouvons pas
connaître le prix réel du médicament
ensuite devons-nous aussi accepter plus
d'aide publique pour les industriels
dans le champ des relocalisations
peut-être mais en attendant les aides
comme vous l'avez rappelé doivent
s'assortir d'obligation de permettre à
l'industriel et d'obliger cette
industriel à produire le médicament dans
le temps et ensuite on exige et c'est le
cas au CEPS que toutes les aides
publiques soient publiées afin d'en
connaître le montant
alors aujourd'hui comme je voulais
annoncer là le prix sont revendiqués par
les industriels d'abord par le
positionnement d'un prix aux États-Unis
car les innovations sont souvent
issues des États-Unis et tiennent compte
de la solvabilité de notre système de
santé et surtout que le nôtre est
solidaire et qu'aux États-Unis aucune
négociation ne se fait jusque là ils
sont en train peut-être d'y venir
alors
devons-nous croire aujourd'hui que la
France
fait mal les médicaments alors dans le
rapport du CEPS 2021 nous avons la
publication en page 14 du montant global
de dépenses sur le médicament
remboursable quel qu'il soit à l'hôpital
à officine en 2021 il est annoncé 30
milliards 4 alors qu'en 2020 c'était 27
milliards 9 ces chiffres sont les prix
affichés ce ne sont pas les prix réels
donc derrière
nous sommes allés en tant qu'association
à la page 63 pour aller s'informer des
remises de médicaments
qui sont satués en fin d'année pour 2020
nous étions à 3 milliards de remise
consenties et en 2021 nous étions à 4
milliards 5 et si on fait le calcul de
soustraire ces remises par rapport au
prix global affiché on se rend compte
qu'entre 2020 et 2021 il y a une
augmentation de plus d'un milliard
d'euros sur les médicaments en général
donc effectivement ça pose question et
ensuite au niveau du prix il faut tenir
compte d'un enjeu majeur qui est la
prescription et les volumes de dépenses
sur un médicament
particulier alors nous avons vécu deux
pénuries récentes bien diffusées et
médiatisés
l'amoxicilline et le paracétamol
pour l'amoxicilline nous sommes le
premier pays consommateur c'est un
antibiotique donc devant le Royaume-Uni
l'Espagne l'Allemagne et l'Italie et
même si les prix ont été réévalués en
Espagne et en Allemagne la consommation
française est-elle qu'au niveau du
volume la dépense est plus importante
que dans ces pays même en ayant augmenté
le prix
pareil pour le paracétamol nous sommes
devant le Royaume-Uni l'Espagne l'Italie
et l'Allemagne devant des prescriptions
massives dans ce pose la question
surtout pour l'antibiotique dont je vous
ai parlé de la pertinence des
prescriptions
ensuite nous avons des propositions à
vous soumettre dans ces propos
liminaires donc d'abord que la
législation qui est en cours soit
appliquée c'est-à-dire le plan de
gestion des pénuries doivent être fait
par les industriels et donner à l'Agence
nationale du médicament
et
les stocks aussi sont de deux mois pour
les médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur et de un mois pour les autres
médicaments
alors d'abord les sanctions sur les
industriels elles sont très rares dans
l'industriels et pris en défaut par
exemple le dernier qui a été sanctionné
c'est pour un défaut de stock il n'avait
que deux jours pour un MITM alors que la
loi leur demande sur le stock national
d'avoir un stock de deux mois la
sanction est tombée mais est-ce que la
NSM au regard de ses exigences c'est en
capacité aujourd'hui de pouvoir vérifier
ces données
ensuite au niveau associatif on a une
demande depuis le début c'est de
prévenir ces pénuries et là se pose la
question des stocks nous avions une loi
qui allait jusqu'à 4 mois de stock mais
le décret qui en est sorti et bien ne
donne que deux mois de stock pour les
amis TM et là nous savons que la moyenne
d'une pénurie c'est 14 semaines
14 semaines ça veut dire qu'il faut
exiger 4 mois de stock pour essayer de
pallier à cette pénurie
nous sommes toujours dans cette demande
pour que
ces pénuries soient prévenu parce qu'on
peut porter effectivement à 4 mois de
stock uniquement les médicaments qui ont
présenté des pénuries dans les deux
dernières années alors là on a un
exemple flagrant c'est l'amoxicilline
dans l'injectable il y avait eu des
pénuries il a été porté à 4 mois et à
l'hôpital il n'y a pas eu de pénurie
d'amoxicillin injectable par contre en
ville il était toujours à deux mois et
là nous avons connu une grave pénurie
qui est amplifiée par la surpression de
l'amoxicilline
donc notre exigence numéro 2 notre
proposition numéro 2 c'est de faire en
sorte que la réglementation aille
jusqu'à 4 mois de stock pour tous les
MITM
troisième proposition
exigée la prise en charge de continuer
la production de médicaments ancien
parce que les pénuries sur la l'étude de
la NSM entre 2012 et 2018 à statué sur
3500 médicaments en pénurie dans ces
années-là et c'est surtout les
médicaments anciens
donc quand on industriel va chercher un
prix au CEPS pour une innovation si la
dans son éventail de médicaments
produits et distribué un ancien
médicament et bien qu'il soit obligé
dans l'obligation de continuer sa
commercialisation en France ce qui fait
que c'était de porter par l'article 30
du PLFSS 2023 qui a été retiré une
partie de l'article 30 qui demandait
justement de négocier en fonction de cet
article là et ça a été retiré hélas à
notre grand désarroi donc nous demandons
que ce soit reporté sur le PLFSS 2024
ensuite c'est le volet qui nous concerne
au niveau des droits des usagers du
système de santé que nous défendons tout
simplement que l'information soit donnée
tant sur il existe une pénurie de la
durée de cette pénurie 3 la cause de
cette pénurie et surtout le traitement
de remplacement de substitution que
l'information soit donnée à la personne
alors certes à la pharmacie il y a aucun
problème si le médicament est en pénurie
l'usagé n'a pas son médicament et il
doit être retardé et le pharmacien donne
en principe l'information qu'il connaît
par contre à l'hôpital aucune
information n'est donnée aux patiente
quand on lui change le médicament et on
sait derrière qu'il y a des pertes de
choses un exemple
et perte de chance ont été publiées dans
une étude qui a été portée au CHU
Édouard Herriot de Lyon sur 4002
personnes traitées pour un cancer de la
vessie entre 2011 et 2016 pendant les
périodes de pénurie il y a eu plus de
récidive ça fait l'objet d'une
publication scientifique ce qui veut
dire que l'incidence de ces pénuries
notamment sur les anticancéreux pour les
personnes qui sont soignées pour un
cancer amèneront une augmentation de la
mortalité à 5 ans telle qu'elle a été
prévue par les oncologues sur l'étude de
la Ligue datant de 2019 et diffusé en
ensuite cinquième demande
c'est alors pour les substitutions j'ai
oublié un poids quand on informe pas le
patient et qu'on lui substitue un
médicament comme contre notre il faut le
lui dire par exemple si c'est quelques
un médicament qui est donné à l'hôpital
en ambulatoire et qu'il rentre chez lui
il va avoir d'autres effets secondaires
que le médicament qu'il connaît et il
faut anticiper ça parce qu'elles peuvent
être graves et si elles sont graves il
faut alerter le patient pour qu'il
puisse avoir recours aux urgences et
peut-être avoir sa vie sauve parce que
ça peut arriver il peut arriver que des
allergies que des effets indésirables
graves soit porté en responsabilité de
cette substitution
ensuite notre demande notre cinquième
demande c'est d'arrêter de courir
derrière des industriels pour envisager
une production des molécules délaissées
par une structure à but non lucratif ou
une structure avec un partenariat public
privé sur toute la chaîne du médicament
alors ça a été sur le rétexte covid ça a
été
réalisé notamment dans des pharmacies en
capacité d'hôpitaux en capacité de
produire ces médicaments ou de les
façonner parce que tout dépend de la
chaîne où on se situe notamment dans
tout ce qui était en pénurie pendant la
covid c'est à dire tous les médicaments
d'anesthésie curare midazolam et ce
façonnage a été réalisé aux Hospices
Civils de Lyon et ce façonnage et cette
réactivité du gouvernement c'était le
COPIL pénurie qui a pris les choses en
main avec la NSM et ça a sauvé des vies
des vies de personnes en réanimation et
des vies de personnes qui étaient
opérées en urgence et il n'y avait pas
dont les médicaments
étaient disponibles et notamment aussi
pour les femmes vie il faut bien appuyer
là-dessus parce que les certaines fin de
vie ont été difficiles sur les pénuries
de midazolam pendant la covid
ensuite donc on a deux demandes au
niveau européen nous travaillons aussi
au niveau européen c'est à dire que les
les pénuries sont un sujet a été un
sujet porté par la France mais qu'on
continue à s'y intéresser et apporter ce
qui est fait en France au niveau
européen mais surtout que
la France soit l'offensive dans la
révision de la stratégie pharmaceutique
de l'Union européenne avec une
harmonisation un minima sur les
réglementations françaises et avec des
stocks de produits semi-finis au niveau
européen qui pourrait servir justement
les industriels au niveau français ou
européen quand il y a une pénurie d'un
composant sur un médicament
donc en conclusion
en conclusion nous regrettons un système
opaque
les prix qui ne prennent pas en compte
les volumes de la prescription
l'opacité du prix entre le prix facial
les remises par classe de médicaments ou
par médicament l'opacité des aides
publiques et l'opacité non prise en
compte des coûts je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
madame Juliana
oui il faut appuyer
merci madame la Présidente
madame la rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
merci d'avoir invité Médecin du Monde à
participer de cette audition médecin du
monde défend un système de santé
inclusif solidaire et pérenne et c'est à
ce titre que nous nous que nous nous
sommes mobilisés depuis de nombreuses
années sur les enjeux de prix et d'accès
aux médicaments à l'innovation
thérapeutique mais aussi au traitement
anciens mais nécessaire efficace
ce problème est apparu de manière
évidente dans les pays plus riches en
2014 au moment de l'arrivée des
antiviraux à action directe contre
l'hépatite C lorsque la firme qu'il y a
donc introduit le Sophus bovir au prix
de 41000 euros la cure alors que près de
230 000 personnes vivaient en France
avec le virus de l'hépatite C
pour la première fois l'état français
avait rationné l'accès au traitement en
raison du prix et limiter la prise en
charge du Sophus bovir au patient avec
des stades de fibrose hépatique les plus
avancées
l'état gérait alors l'urgence au dépend
d'une politique ambitieuse d'accès pour
toutes et tous à même de mettre fin à
l'épidémie
depuis 2014 nous continuons de dénoncer
les abus commis par de nombreuses firmes
dans leur stratégie de fixation de prix
des nouvelles thérapies ces stratégies
ont été largement documentées notamment
par le Sénat américain dans le cas du
Sophus bovir et par la Cour des comptes
en 2014 2017 pardon le rapport technique
de l'OMS sur le prix des anticancéreux
souligne que les prix des médicaments
sont fixés par le niveau de profit
maximal qu'il permet de produire ceux au
sein d'une industrie qui impose des
marges très élevées
ce modèle de prix nécessairement
inflationniste et motivé par un
paradigme dit
fondé sur la valeur qui revient
finalement à donner un prix à la vie
en France c'est surtout l'évaluation de
l'amélioration du service médical rendu
par les nouveaux traitements qui jouent
ce rôle et détermine la stratégie des
firmes dans la négociation des prix avec
l'État or ce paradigme ne prend pas en
compte l'équilibre des systèmes de santé
il rend les déterminants du prix opaque
en raison d'une acceptation
disproportionnée par les États du secret
des affaires ainsi les données des
essais cliniques les financements les
résultats et les échecs ne sont pas
transparents pas plus que nos leçons le
cadre des négociations et les
déterminants réels des prix
les prix élevés sont aujourd'hui au cœur
du modèle économique des firmes
multinationales pour lesquelles les
brevets viennent jouer un rôle central
en assurant une situation de monopole
d'exploitation la propriété
intellectuelle est le fondement
juridique qui permet de contrôler
l'offre et la disponibilité dans des
systèmes de santé à ressources limitées
créant une situation de rareté
artificielle et de pression sur les
budgets de la santé ainsi certaines
entreprises pharmaceutiques n'hésitent
plus à ne pas investir les marchés
européens considérant les prix trop
faibles
c'est ainsi le cas pour le cas de
Bluebird avec la thérapie génique
intéglo contre la bêta thalassémie dans
le Prix approche les 3 millions de
dollars par patient ce modèle pose
d'importants déséquilibres d'un côté un
soutien important des pouvoirs publics
pour mettre sur le marché de nouveaux
médicaments par la recherche publique
les subventions aux entreprises une mise
à disposition précoce pour les patients
et le consentement à des prix élevés par
l'Assurance Maladie de l'autre
une stratégie lacunaire pour la mise à
disposition d'anciens médicaments
essentiels considéré comme
insuffisamment rentable par les
entreprises ce qui participe aux
situations de pénurie auxquelles la
France fait face actuellement dans ces
deux situations la pérennité et l'accès
abordable doivent être au cœur des
solutions qui ne peuvent être pensées en
distant distinguant ces deux enjeux
fondamentalement liés face à ces
constats nous avons des propositions
très concrètes que nos défendons depuis
plusieurs années nous nous permettons
également de vous renvoyer ou
recommandations du rapport de la Cour
des comptes de 2017
donc premièrement l'état d'un renforcer
les moyens qu'il se donnent pour
négocier les prix de l'innovation
thérapeutique en installant la
transparence des cours réels des
traitements des tétèrent les
déterminants de ces prix et des
conditions de ces négociations le comité
économique des produits de santé devait
être en mesure de prendre en compte
l'apport des financements publics dans
la recherche et développement des
médicaments pendant la négociation des
prix
deuxièmement le ministre de la santé
doit être en mesure de multiplier ses
sources d'aprisonnement
d'approvisionnement pardon et déclencher
la licence d'office lorsqu'un brevet est
exploité dans des conditions contraires
à l'intérêt de la santé publique pour
répondre aux crises posées par des prix
anormalement élevés la licence d'office
a été mise en place sous la présidence
du général de Gaulle les gouvernements
successives n'ont pas su ou voulu se
saisir de cet outil plus grave ils n'ont
jamais créé les conditions
réglementaires pour faire que cette
option soit même réalisable
ce qui de fait vide de sa puissance cet
outil de négociation
l'article
r613-10 du Code de la propriété
intellectuelle prévoit la création d'une
commission chargée d'apprécier les cas
concrets de licence d'office cette
commission n'a jamais été
[Musique]
fondée c'est pourquoi nous attirons
votre attention sur l'importance de
donner un corps légal juridique et
réglementaire à cet outil prévu dans
notre droit mais aussi dans le droit
international et troisièmement nous
demandons un renforcement de
l'application de la France dans la
gouvernance des pratiques de l'Office
européen des brevets Médecins du monde a
pu montrer par des oppositions au brevet
et des observations de tiers devant cet
office que les revendications dans les
brevets déposés par les firmes étaient
abusives et mérité
nous suggérons donc à votre commission
mesdames et messieurs
d'auditionner l'Office européen des
brevets mais aussi les représentants de
la France dans cette office afin de
rendre des comptes sur les pratiques
vis-à-vis de la propriété intellectuelle
des produits de santé pour que celle-ci
ne crée pas des barrières
supplémentaires ou des retards dans
l'accès des médicaments génériques et
biomimilaires enfin il est nécessaire de
réformer et repenser les modèles de
recherche et développement pour penser à
l'accès en amont notamment lors du
transfert des technologies de la
recherche fondamentale
majoritairement public vers les
industriels il convient donc d'exiger
des contreparties claires lors de cette
étape à savoir transparence des
courriels de recherche et développement
partage de la propriété intellectuelle
et prix abordable merci
merci beaucoup madame allemands
mesdames et messieurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci de nous recevoir donc le collectif
santé en danger
qui est donc un collectif de soignants
de terrain et qui représente l'ensemble
des professions de santé
en ville et à l'hôpital il a un rôle de
sentinelle
il permet des alertes sur les thèmes de
la santé et ils travaillent sur des
propositions concrètes en lien avec le
terrain
des propositions ont été émises
d'ailleurs dans les suites du vrai Ségur
de la santé avec des auditions d'experts
pendant 6 semaines à qui on a demandé
des avis sur des problématiques de
terrain qui ont été rapportés auprès des
lieux locaux
le collectif santé en danger considère
qu'il y a une que la démocratie
sanitaire est en danger avec en
particulier la fermeture des services
d'urgence les désert médicaux la
fermeture de maternité et on assiste à
une perte d'attractivité du métier de la
santé en général avec des nombreux
Français 6 millions qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant
nous sommes donc tous ici pour défendre
une même cause une démocratie sanitaire
et un accès aux soins de qualité pour
tous et pour défendre notre floron
national qui est la santé concernant
plus précisément la pénurie de
médicaments en 2017 on constaté une
tension sur 500 médicaments
30% déjà de plus qu'en 2016 malgré un
rapport du Sénat alarmant en 2018 la
situation a été délaissée du débat
public
aujourd'hui on dénombre là en mars 2023
372 médicaments qui font l'objet de
rupture de difficultés
d'approvisionnement et ce depuis ces
trois dernières années
alors parmi ces médicaments on peut se
dire que il n'y a pas que des
médicaments essentiels certes mais une
majorité plus de 50% compte parmi les
médicaments essentiels de l'OMS
et ces médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutiques majeurs ou médicament
essentiels ne disposent pas ou
suffisamment d'alternatives
thérapeutiques égales disponible sur le
marché
alors on aimerait se rassurer sur
l'excellence de notre système de santé
français vantés par ces dernières
décennies
mais historiquement on est une puissance
industrielle dans la fabrication du
médicament mais on dispose encore de 271
usines sur notre territoire avec 35 000
salariés
mais la France est passée de la place de
première européenne à la place de
quatrième européenne en termes de
production pharmaceutique
le commerce du méridiquement il reste
malgré tout fleurissant avec 3,2
milliards de boîtes vendus par an
par ailleurs l'innovation de l'industrie
est plutôt bien soutenue dans notre pays
avec un financement public non
négligeable
mais alors comment expliquer ces
dernières années que un tiers des
Français ça a été dit déclare avoir subi
à titre personnel une pénurie de
médicaments
sa girait-il d'un effet direct de la
crise covid se résorbant peu à peu non
en 2023 le rythme des nouvelles ruptures
de stock est supérieure à celui des
remises à disposition et cela concerne
respectivement 12 et 14 médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur en
janvier et février 2023
alors quand on parle de médicaments en
fait on parle de quel médicament on
parle de vaccin
qui altèrent la couverture vaccinale et
la santé publique comme les vaccins
rougeurs au rayon rubéole comme les
vaccins d'été polio comme les vaccins
hépatite B et pacita les vaccins
antirabique les antibiotiques donc
l'amoxicilline l'Augmentin la cortisone
par voie intraveineuse l'aspégic
intraveineux indispensable au traitement
des accidents vasculaires cérébraux
des chimiothérapies
des médicaments anti-rogés ça a été
évoqué au cours de des différentes
auditions
voilà donc en fait c'est des médicaments
qui sont plutôt des médicaments
d'intérêt vraiment général d'intérêt de
thérapeutique majeur connu du grand
public donc ce n'est pas seulement des
médicaments de niche qui sont concernés
il s'agit d'ailleurs le plus souvent des
médicaments anciens et matures
ces ruptures d'approvisionnement on peut
le voir sur le terrain conduisent à une
perte de chance inacceptable pour les
patients avec une nette mise en danger
une mise en danger vraiment objective
et c'est aussi
[Musique]
une mise en difficulté d'une
fonctionnement de notre système de santé
au niveau de des établissements de santé
et des officines de ville des pharmacies
il y a une gestion coûteuse de ces
pénuries avec une mise en difficulté des
pharmaciens des acteurs de terrain et
sur un fonds de crise économique
énergétique et géopolitique on peut
imaginer que c'est rien n'est fait le
phénomène va s'aggraver dans les
prochains mois et dans les prochaines
années
alors on considère qu'il y a une mise en
danger de notre de notre souveraineté
sanitaire en France d'ailleurs dans son
rapport Liga ce que constate un gain
étroit entre la problématique des
pénuries de médicaments et souveraineté
sanitaires
en effet l'indépendance sanitaire de
notre pays est remise en cause et pour
plusieurs raisons comme vous le savez la
fabrication des principes actifs des
médicaments essentiels est largement
délocalisé 80% des substances actives
consommées en France sont fabriqués à
l'étranger essentiellement Chine et
contre 20% il y a 30 ans
la production est également plus
compliquée au niveau technologique et à
la problématique du conditionnement qui
se pose et il faut répondre aux lois de
l'offre et de la demande et ceci est
régi par un commerce mondial les prix
sont négociés au plus bas en tout cas
plus bas que certains de nos voisins
européens
donc en cas de pénurie conjoncturelle
mondiale par exemple à défaut de
fournisseurs la logique patriotique fait
que la France et l'Union européenne ne
seront plus prioritaires pour les
livraisons de médicaments
la pandémie a d'ailleurs mise en lumière
des difficultés d'approvisionnement mais
a-t-on oublié maintenant la
problématique de nos stocks de masse
par ailleurs il y a une certaine opacité
dans l'origine de ces ruptures
d'approvisionnement tout n'est pas très
bien identifié les causes ne sont pas
très bien établies dans une publication
de frontières une pharmacologie on a 50%
seulement on a pardon 50% des cas où
cette origine de pénurie n'est pas
clairement établie
au niveau du terrain on a des
conséquences comme je vous le disais
qu'ils sont très préoccupantes
en effet les traitements de remplacement
sont moins bien adaptés avec des risques
accrus d'infir indésirables augmentent
les risques d'erreurs médicamenteuses et
on perd particulier dans la population
pédiatrique
les prescriptions d'antibiotiques et de
médicaments alizés cardiovasculaires se
font par défaut et il n'est pas rare à
ce jour après témoignage de pharmacien
que sur cinq médicaments prescrits seuls
deux médicaments puissent être délivrés
ces pénuries ont ainsi obligé certains
parents par exemple à quitter Paris pour
Bruxelles en quête d'un flacon
d'amoxicilline pour leur enfant
[Musique]
de par l'effet de ces ruptures les
patients sont moins bien soignés avec
des risques de perte de chances non
négligeable
les professionnels de terrain tels que
les médecins généralistes ont le
sentiment de subir ces pénuries aucune
information ne leur est fournie ou les
minimum ni sur les causes ni sur la
durée ni sur les solutions envisagées
aucune cartographie n'est publiée
concernant les lieux de délivrance ou
non obligeant les prescripteurs à
contacter les pharmacies une à une pour
leur patient ou laissant partir les
patients faire la tournée des officines
c'est la réalité du terrain encore
aujourd'hui
vous avez encore des
oui votre intervention est longue encore
non après on reviendra aux propositions
après comme vous voulez donc bien sûr on
a plusieurs propositions à vous faire
un autre constat c'est que par ailleurs
la France ne dispose d'aucun outil
permettant une bonne estimation de ses
stocks de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeurs et depuis 2021 un
certain nombre de médicaments doivent
disposer d'un stock minimal de sécurité
comme on l'a dit et les industries
doivent établir des PGP mais CGP
sont-ils bien régulés et bien contrôlés
comme ça déjà été évoqué
par ailleurs on reviendra donc sur la
difficulté d'une coopération européenne
et sur la difficulté de s'entendre au
niveau des prix au niveau des
étiquetages il y a bien sûr une
nécessité de relocalisation de notre
industrie à l'échelle française et
européenne
donc
voilà donc plutôt les contraintes
d'ordre de la gouvernance avec un manque
de pilotage sur l'organisation avec
beaucoup d'acteurs mais il manque de
coordination et clairement qui entraîne
une manque d'efficacité sur le terrain
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
donc monsieur prouet
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteuse mais des cieux les sénateurs
mais ça me délicieux les salariés du
Sénat qui nous permettent de
retransmettre merci de cette audition
donc du collectif de santé en danger est
plus particulièrement j'en étais
l'animateur et l'initiateur le collectif
brevé sur les vaccins icovis stop
réquisition qui s'est posé en France
mais évidemment encore plus à l'échelle
européenne avec l'initiative citoyenne
européenne et surtout à l'Organisation
mondiale du commerce au moment où se
discuter les accords ou les la levée des
brevets cette question
a faillite du constat de faillite qu'il
faut bien tirer du médicament
marchandise du vaccin marchandise dont
la gestion a été déléguée non pas à
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé
mais à l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce et à la gestion par les brevets
de cette médaille où l'une face et la
pénurie mais l'autre face si vous
refusez la pénurie c'est la bataille
pour obtenir des bras des biens raréfiés
grâce au brevets et dont les prix
explosent c'est une longue histoire donc
celle
de la réquisition des médicaments bien
communs et en remontant un peu
l'histoire en France ils redit de
l'histoire j'ai trouvé qu'en
1918 à la fois pendant la Première
Guerre mondiale et à la fois pendant la
pandémie grippale la Société chimique
des usines du Rhône à péage du
Roussillon avait préféré vendre fort
cher son aspirine pour lutter contre la
fièvre qu'amenait cette grippe qui a tué
presque 50 millions de personnes et
l'exporter à l'étranger et que le
gouvernement de l'époque avait
réquisitionné ou avait menacé de
réquisitionner pour permettre la
libération des stocks et la baisse des
prix
c'est à propos d'un événement plus
récent évidemment le sarzkopf 2 que je
voudrais revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
en France mais aussi à l'échelle
internationale mon propos je pourrais le
résumer en disant
le code génétique du sarzkopf2 a été
rendu public tout de suite par le
gouvernement chinois
n'a pas souhaité
breveté ni la conséquence génétique ni
même les séquences autour de la protéine
Spike qui aurait pu permettre et qui ont
permis d'ailleurs le développement de
vaccins donc c'est quand génétique
publique
les deux brevets qui ont permis et qui
permettront demain de refaire d'autres
vaccins ARN était en fait issus de la
recherche publique je pense par exemple
au boivré 2000 sorties en 2005 de
l'Université de Pennsylvanie qui avec
une substitution d'Amine permet de
diminuer le caractère inflammatoire des
vaccins ARN et je pense au vaccin au
vaccin au brevet 0,70 de du gouvernement
américain qui permet de stabiliser l'ARN
grâce à ces microbilles de lipides qui
permettent donc l'efficacité du vaccin
en fait entre le code génétique et ces
deux brevets publiques nous avions la
maquette qui permet de fabriquer ses
vaccins à RN messagers aujourd'hui
contre le Sarko mais demain peut-être
contre des cancers ou d'autres molécules
bien
mais qu'est-ce qui est public aussi
c'est les milliards d'euros qui ont été
déversés difficiles à tous connaître
puisque le secret des affaires nous en
empêche sur l'industrie pharmaceutique
pour produire ses vaccins je pense par
exemple au 17 milliards d'euros de la
barre d'américaine des 2 milliards
d'euros de l'Union européenne des 1,7
milliards d'euros de livres sterling du
gouvernement anglais alors vous me direz
et bien on a eu des vaccins le on n'est
pas tout à fait vrai sauf à penser que
nous sommes français blanc dans un pays
riche et que nous sommes le 11 le on en
cas de pandémie c'est le monde entier et
que le monde entier est privé de vaccins
le risque au-delà de l'aspect moral et
scandaleux c'est l'émergence de variants
qui augmente à tel point scandale qui
n'a pas échappé mais qui a pas échappé à
des institutions sûrement un petit peu
plus noble que moi je vous citerai par
exemple édito du British pédical Journal
de Fatima Hassan sud-africaine qui s'est
battu à l'époque contre les procès de
pretorias sur les 21 plus grandes
creuses de la pharmacie qui ne voulaient
pas génériques les antirétroviraux elle
a dit le refus à l'OMC de la levée des
brevets British medicon journal le plus
vieux et le plus prestigieux journal
médical au monde c'est un crime contre
l'humanité
plus mesuré dans ses propos mais il a
plus de liens avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique le landset quand même qui
nous disait dans un éditorial il du
comité éditorial du 27 il est urgent de
supprimer les médicaments et
technologies de santé du champ
d'application de cet accord à savoir
celui de l'OMC bien
quel était on va prendre un temps t
celui ou 6,5 milliards de vaccins ont
été injectés et de voir quel était la
répartition de la vaccination à ce
moment
qui est incluse de fait parce que les
brevets ont permis de négocier des prix
extrêmement haut alors que j'ai dit
qu'ils sont fondés sur la recherche
publique sur les crédits publics quand
les 6,5 premières milliards de doses ont
été injectés
75% de ces doses ont été faits dans les
10 pays les plus riches ce qui a permis
de vacciner 61% des Européens 67% des
Américains seulement
4,5% des habitants des pays à faible
revenu donc en avançant dans la
démonstration on voit que le système des
brevets a été assis en fait sur des
brevets et des crédits publics
que le système des brevets essayer
d'avoir les chiffres des financements
totaux des vaccins par le commissure
européenne vous aurez beaucoup de mal
essayez de savoir le prix qu'à payer
Monsieur Olivier verront pour le
rendecivir que l'étude solidarité a dit
inefficace 63 millions d'euros 300000
doses
2100 euros la dose alors que l'étude
solidaritive venait de démontrer que le
règne des civires antivirales contre le
covid était non seulement
inefficace mais dangereux pour les reins
mais le brevet et les accords inclut
aussi le fait qu'avec 15 jours entre la
remise de l'étude solidarité et le fait
de rendre public ces éléments pendant
ces 15 jours giléad a fait du forcing
pour vendre à la Commission européenne à
ce prix c'est ce médicament inefficace
et dangereux dans le même temps
l'Ukraine réussissait auprès d'un
génériqueur pakistanais à acheter le
même produit pour 20 euros 45 bien donc
nos systèmes de sécurité sociale ont
financé
très cher ce qui avait déjà été financé
par la recherche publique quand je dis
très cher il n'est pas si facile que ça
de savoir les prix payés pour les
vaccins en France mais on peut faire une
opération on allait revoir le PLFSS plus
5 milliards d'euros pour le processus de
vaccination Monsieur Olivier Véran a dit
que
la location des stades des kits d'Arena
le paiement des personnes elle est tout
ça c'était autour de 2,5 milliards
d'euros on peut donc penser que grosso
modo le chiffre de l'achat des vaccins
en France est au tour de 2,5 milliards
d'euros les sénateurs qui sont
soucieuses de la dépense publique feront
le rapprochement avec les difficultés de
l'hôpital public parce que
l'établissement pharmaceutique de santé
publique France qui a payé ça aurait pu
sûrement les négocier à bien meilleur
prix et je me suis amusé entre
guillemets à utiliser les éléments
excusez-moi parce que c'est une
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie de
médicaments
[Musique]
que nous on a eu c'est parce que
d'autres ne les ont pas eu
par rapport aux problématiques actuelles
de pénurie de médicaments en France
la porte d'entrée c'est le brevet j'ai
bien compris ça mais il y a eu
l'Internet
il y a une alternative au brevet le
sarzkopf de la montrer qu'en moderna a
qui n'avait jamais produit de manière
industrielle un seul vaccin ARN a eu des
subventions elle a choisi de passer
accord avec le l'industriel Suisse
[Musique]
lonzo qui a fabriqué en trois mois à
vierge une entreprise qui sortait une
ligne de 6 millions de vaccins ARN et
plus intéressant enfin voilà aussi
intéressant Public Citizen une
association de consommateurs américaines
fameuse depuis les procès nathalidomie
et tout ça a réussi à montrer qu'avec
9,5 milliards d'euros on pouvait
fabriquer
sur 5 Sites décentralisés 17 lignes de
production avec 1300 personnels et que
ça ça permettait pour 9,5 milliards
d'euros de fabriquer à peu près 9
milliards de doses 9 milliards de dos
c'est-à-dire de vacciner tous ceux qui
n'avaient pas pu être vacciner mon
propos en clair il est que le système
des brevets a failli le système de l'OMC
a failli c'est l'OMS et les brevets
publiques qui permettrait à la fois
de réduire les pénuries de réduire la
pression sur la sécurité sociale parce
que je reviens quand même un instant 2,5
milliards d'euros payés à Pfizer et
moderna c'est l'équivalent de 59
000 infirmiers et infirmières
salaires plus cotisations sociales
embauchée et que on a bien vu je
terminerai là-dessus que toutes les
problèmes de transparence ont généré ce
qu'on a vu c'est à dire une défiance
généralisée de la population et
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas soigner
une population sans son accord et sa
présence et que la démocratie sanitaire
elle passera aussi par la rupture des
liens incestueux entre l'industrie
pharmaceutique et
les brevets pour que les médicaments ne
soient plus des marchandises mais des
biens communs discuter ensemble à l'OMS
et pas à l'OMC
merci beaucoup monsieur Duguet
merci beaucoup bonjour à tous merci de
nous exploser les 5 minutes quand même
là pour tout le monde
donc voilà alors je vais essayer de vous
parler de pénurie justement et en
parlant en tant qu'association de malade
de malades concernés par des maladies
rares
ultra voir dans certains cas mégarar et
pour mieux situer de là où je parle
simplement rappeler rapidement la
définition officielle d'une maladie rare
c'est moins d'une personne sur 2000 mais
on a 7000 maladies rares à peu près qui
ont été identifiés et parmi ces 7000
maladies rares 85% représente moins
d'une personne par millions moins d'une
personne par millions pour 85% de cette
de ces maladies mais mis bout à bout
comme on a quand même beaucoup de
maladies
ça concerne en France un français sur 20
ça concerne 3 millions de personnes et
pour ces 3 millions de personnes
l'impact des pénuries de médicaments
elles en sont victimes mais elles en
sont victimes je
n'insisterai sur trois points sur trois
points particuliers le premier ça sera
victime du fait elle de n'avoir aucun
traitement pour la majorité je vais
venir dessus le deuxième point c'est
qu'elles sont aussi concernées par de
nombreux utilisations hors mêmes de
vieux médicaments et quand il y a des
pénuries elles en sont encore beaucoup
plus victimes je reviendrai dessus et
puis le troisième point c'est que ces
trois personnes qui sont concernées par
des maladies rares malheureusement dans
la maladie il n'y a pas de lourd
anti-cumulent et ces personnes et bien
il y a beaucoup de cumulards en plus
d'avoir une maladie rare elles ont aussi
toutes les autres maladies de la
population française et donc quand il y
a des pénuries ça rajoute de la charge à
la charge et je finirai sur ce point là
alors premier point c'est celui sur
cette pénurie massive de l'inexistence
de traitement je vous parle de ces 7000
maladies
95% des maladies rares non aucun
traitement spécifique et aucun
traitement qui permet de changer de
façon importante ou significative le
cours de la maladie donc retenons bien
ce chiffre là sur ces 3 millions de
patients 95%, il y a rien alors depuis
quelques années c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle et on le voit arrive et se
multiplie des traitements pour des
maladies rares
arrive il y en a quand même 7000
maladies derrière
ces traitements se multiplient et on ne
peut que s'enthousiasmer du fait que les
progrès de la science permettent
aujourd'hui notamment grâce à des
approches et des traitements innovants
comme sont les génothérapies permettent
de donner des perspectives scientifiques
et médicales de traitement y compris à
des maladies qui sont des maladies
mégarares c'est-à-dire ces maladies du
moins d'une personne pour 3 millions
le problème c'est que si cette
perspective scientifique est médicale
est particulièrement enthousiasmante
pour les patients qui depuis des années
n'ont rien et sont dans des situations
sans aucune alternative grave et bien
les perspectives économiques et
commerciales elles sont beaucoup moins
enthousiasme elles sont beaucoup moins
enthousiasmants avec on le constate
l'arrivée de certains traitements à des
prix
excessivement importants mais surtout et
c'est surtout là-dessus que je voudrais
insister là-dessus le problème est
surtout de ces produits pour lesquels
médicalement scientifiquement il y a des
choses très porteuses qui existent et
pour lesquelles et nous le craignons de
plus en plus il n'y aura pas de modèle
économiques et commercial qui vont
permettre que ces traitements ces
preuves de concept c'est possible unité
de traitement se traduisent réellement
par des traitements pour pour les
personnes et donc sur cette question ne
nous focalisons pas simplement sur ce
qui arrive mais qui arrivent à très cher
qu'il faut régler c'est aussi sur tous
ces autres parce que là et je tiens à
insister là-dessus nous sommes nous en
tant que plus qu'observateur et acteurs
de ce secteur particulièrement
inquiet des évolutions de ces derniers
mois particulièrement inquiets pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison
c'est que on observe pour les maladies
les plus rares parmi les rares parmi ces
maladies pour les mégarains un
retournement des marchés financiers
c'est-à-dire des investissements qui ces
dernières années se sont faits parce que
c'était un moyen à travers des maladies
méga rares de pouvoir
arriver sur la maîtrise de telle ou
telle technologie en vue d'aller après
sur des maladies fréquentes et bien
maintenant se détourne de ces projets
qui sont des projets dont les preuves de
concept souvent venues de de petites
biotech ou venues de l'académique sont
particulièrement porteurs donc premier
point
ces projets vont plus pouvoir émerger et
se retrouvent dans des situations qui
sont des situations que nous l'ont
qualifie aujourd'hui et bien de maladies
ultra ou Mégara pour lesquels il n'y a
pas de modèle commercial permettant de
pouvoir espérer que les traitements
arrivent jusqu'au et puis la deuxième
chose qui nous inquiète aussi dans les
évolutions de ces derniers mois et bien
c'est le constat qui compris certains
laboratoires qui ont développé des
traitements qui ont des traitements qui
ont été autorisés et l'exemple de
Bluebird bio a été signé a été signalé
tout à l'heure puisque ça a été je
dirais le premier signal d'alarme qui
malheureusement a été suivi depuis et
quand même un exemple particulièrement
choquant d'un laboratoire américain qui
a obtenu deux autorisations de mise sur
le marché pour des maladies
excessivement rares et excessivement
graves en France et donc on a cité tout
à l'heure la bêta thalassémie là mais la
deuxième qui est l'adréno loco
dystrophie son médicament le schizona
qui concerne en France pour cette
maladie très grave de l'enfant c'était
de 2 à 3 patients à traiter par an en
France et bien à retirer son
autorisation de mise sur le marché du
niveau européen pour purement et
simplement se retirer du marché européen
et se recentrer uniquement sur le marché
américain et la situation est d'autant
plus choquante que pour ces deux
produits ces deux produits étaient issus
à l'origine de recherche académique
française
et donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui dans
une situation où ces produits ne sont
plus disponibles ni en Europe et ni en
France alors que ils sont en train
d'être mis à disposition des patients
américains alors sur ce point vraiment
pour toutes ces maladies qui sont des
maladies
ultra rares sans modèle commercial il
nous sommes prioritaires aujourd'hui
d'inventer de nouveaux dispositifs qui
vont permettre de pouvoir donner non pas
un accès au marché mais un accès aux
patients c'est-à-dire un nouveau modèle
qui permet de pouvoir développer pour
ces maladies
ultra rares sans modèle commercial un
nouveau dispositif et nous nous appelons
nos vœux pour ainsi vous voulez en
reparler la gueule sur la foi un modèle
d'exception un modèle
arrêtons de penser finalement c'est une
logique d'exception c'est-à-dire c'est
un modèle adapté à l'ultra rareté de
maladies qui concernent énormément de
monde et pour lesquels et pour lesquels
la logique de mise sur le marché d'un
traitement où on commence à faire un
essai sur un petit échantillon avant que
ça soit généralisé à la grande quantité
et puis avec une mm au milieu ça ne
marche pas pour des maladies ou dans
l'essai cliniques on a déjà mis en
traitement tous les malades et ou après
il y a pas de modèle économique pour le
financer et donc nous appelons notre
vœux d'un fond d'innovation publique
permettant de pouvoir intervenir pour le
développement et le traitement de ces
maladies ultra rares sans modèle
commercial deuxième point que j'avais
annoncé d'entrée qui est celui de toutes
ces médicaments utilisés pour des
maladies rares qui sont très souvent des
vieux médicaments qui sont utilisés en
elles-mêmes ce sont des centaines
d'utilisations dans les maladies rares
et pour lesquelles trop souvent c'est à
l'occasion d'une rupture ou d'un abandon
du médicament du vieux médicament
d'origine par le laboratoire
que l'on découvre et bien que ces
utilisations étaient utilisées pour des
maladies rares pour autre d'autres
effets thérapeutiques mais pouvaient
avoir un effet thérapeutique
particulièrement important et pour ce
sujet là malgré les efforts qui ont été
faits notamment dans le cadre du
troisième plan national maladies rares
et j'espère qu'il y aura un quatrième
plan qui pourra aussi poursuivre ses
efforts et bien on a encore loin du
compte pour réussir à trouver là encore
le modèle économique qui permet de
stabiliser de développer de pérenniser
ces médicaments je vais vous citer un
exemple concret pour une de nos maladies
pour un lieu médicament qui était le
seul butamol le salbutamol non pas celui
qui est utilisé dans l'asthme sous forme
de nébulisation mais sous forme de
comprimés ou de sirop il était utilisé
en obstétrique
il y a une dizaine d'années 2013
exactement
bien d'autres médicaments étant beaucoup
plus efficace et le rapport bénéfices
n'étant plus considéré comme suffisant
l'agence européenne a retiré la même
on s'est rendu compte à cette occasion
là qui avait en France entre deux et
trois cent passants concernés par des
maladies rares notamment à maladie
s'appelle les syndromes myasthéniques
congénitaux pour lesquels ce médicament
a un effet spectaculaire chez certains
patients quand j'ai dit spectaculaire
chez certains patients c'est le cas de
patients qui sont en errance diagnostic
pendant des années et qui sont en
fauteuil roulant depuis plusieurs années
quand la maladie est correctement
diagnostiquée et qu'ils ont accès à ce
traitement qui vaut juste quelques euros
ce sont des personnes qui se remettent à
marcher donc c'est rare d'avoir des
effets aussi spectaculaires depuis une
dizaine d'années ce traitement il était
importé grâce au laboratoire en
utilisant des stocks d'autres pays ou il
en restait encore un peu nous arrivons
aujourd'hui à une situation de pénurie
où la NSM malgré ses efforts à de plus
en plus de mal à trouver dans le monde
des dieux stocks qui restent et
aujourd'hui plus aucun laboratoire ne
veut investir pour redévelopper pour 200
patients en France pour une molécule qui
ne coûte plus rien et les patients sont
dans une très grande inquiétude
aujourd'hui de la pérennité de la
possibilité qu'il puisse ne pas être
dans la situation ou si ce médicament
n'est plus là ça veut dire qu'il ceux
qui sont passés du fauteuil et qui se
sont remis à marcher depuis plusieurs
années n'auront plus d'autres solutions
que de repasser aux fauteuil c'est un
exemple concret c'est un exemple
d'actualité il est urgent qu'il puisse y
avoir des dispositifs permettant de le
faire et puis dernier point je finirai
là-dessus je l'avais dit je disais que
les malades maladies rares ils sont
aussi concernés par toutes les autres
maladies
ils sont quand on est concernés par une
maladie ou déjà au quotidien avec la
lourdeur la complexité de la maladie
plus la très grande dépendance que ça
peut générer on a déjà tout ça à gérer
lorsque en plus on se retrouve parce que
on a une autre infection qui arrive à
devoir gérer l'angoisse du manque
d'amocicilline de corticoïdes ou de
paracétamol que même si ça ne se voit
pas parce que pour le patient finalement
il y a eu une continuité de traitement
mais cette continuité de traitement elle
a été au prix de 5 déplacements à la
pharmacie d'avoir été de voir dans
d'autres pharmacies ici le médicament
était pas là ou pas de d'avoir attendu
les médicaments au goût de par goutte et
bien et je crois qu'il faut pas le
maîtriser qu'il faut vraiment l'avoir en
tête on rajoute au fardeau de la maladie
qui est déjà très lourd pour ses
patients là un fardeau un poids un poids
psychologique qui est particulièrement
important même si on a l'impression
qu'ils ont eu une continuité de
traitement et ce point il faut
absolument bien le prendre en compte je
vous remercie très bien merci beaucoup
donc je vais laisser la parole Laurence
Cohen notre rapporteur pour une série de
questions je sais pas si dans les
collègues certains veulent poser une
question il va pas y avoir le temps on
peut d'abord
question écrite de votre part
moi je vais vous remercier chacun
chacune parce que parce que vous avez
quand même exposé en peu de temps même
si ça a dépassé les 5 minutes mais
rassurez-vous vous avez pas été seul
parce que hier le lait m'a fait
exactement pareil donc chacun c'est dur
de rester dans les 5 minutes
réglementaire mais sur les tables rondes
comme vous êtes nombreux voilà donc moi
je vous remercie parce que du coup il y
a plusieurs de mes questions auxquelles
vous avez déjà répondu donc ça c'est pas
mal donc ça va m'éviter dans dans poser
mais quand même quelques quelques
éléments que je voudrais voir voir
préciser
par exemple au niveau de de France
assaut santé donc vous avez
effectivement parlé de la révision de la
législation pharmaceutique de l'Union
européenne dont normalement la
présentation devait se faire fin mars et
avec la présidente Sonia de la provoté
on est allé la semaine dernière à
Bruxelles et on arriver au moment où
donc c'était bloqué donc on a eu
différents interlocuteurs Européens à
qui on a posé la question comment se
fait-il que alors que c'était prévu dans
les jours qui venaient et bien les
choses ont été bloquées il y a eu
beaucoup d'embarras de nous
il s'est dit de manière très
diplomatique il y a eu beaucoup
d'embarras nous n'avons pas eu de
réponse à nos questions par contre nos
interlocuteurs pour certains d'entre eux
et je pense notamment à une députée
européenne c'est montrer inquiète de ce
report en disant que il fallait qu'on
soit très attentif et attentive parce
que ça n'était pas quelques jours mais
ça pouvait
être éloigné voire d'une année donc
c'est c'est très très préjudiciable donc
si vous pouviez apporter quelques
quelques éléments parce que on nous a
quand même dit que il y avait des
lobbies forts qui empêchaient en fait
ces réglementation qui est préjudiciable
sur tous les pays européens au-delà ça
c'est ma première pas que des lobbyings
de laboratoire du restant
comme quoi à partir du moment où je où
je dis lobbying j'ai une étiquette
laboratoire mais rassurez-vous moi je
suis multifactorielle je ne pensais pas
que au laboratoire mais voilà donc ça
c'était ma première question de deuxième
question
peut-être plus particulièrement sur
médecin Médecin du Monde c'est
concernant l'Office européen des brevets
comment est-ce que finalement vous
analysez la jurisprudence de l'Office
européen des brevets sur la notion
d'activités inventive parce que c'est
quelque chose enfin nous là quel que
soit nos sensibilités politiques on est
quand même tous et toutes frappés par le
côté de mettre tous ses œufs dans le
même panier si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
quand il s'agit d'innovation et de
rétropédaler sur les produits matures
donc cette notion d'activité mineure
pardon pas mineur mais inventif peut
avoir des conséquences qui peuvent être
préjudiciables et je voudrais que vous
nous éclairiez là-dessus parce que
est-ce innovation ça rime forcément avec
progrès thérapeutique parfois oui
parfois non donc ça c'était ma deuxième
ma deuxième question et peut-être de
manière plus précise vous l'avez un peu
dit en creux mais le fait que il y ait
des produits assez exorbitants qui
soient obtenus par certains industriels
pour certains médicaments dit innovants
est-ce que ça peut pas conduire
finalement à rationner justement l'accès
aux produits concernés vous l'avez dit
parce qu'il y a aussi le remboursement
de la Sécurité sociale donc moi je suis
assez inquiète du fait qu'il pourrait y
avoir un choix
de patients qui pourraient être
remboursés donc avoir accès à ces
thérapies innovantes c'était ma
troisième question ma quatrième question
et je m'achemine vers la fin c'est plus
à une question pour AFM Téléthon
d'ailleurs la présidente en a parlé le
fait de que
pardon je vais il faut que je remette je
parle plus lentement que
la
le statut particulier de l'entité
industrielle qui au départ devait être
placé sous tutelle du d'une association
et de l'état ce qui était quelque chose
d'intéressant et voilà qui qui aurait pu
porter ses fruits mais qui maintenant
tombe dans le dans le giron d'une d'une
d'un passage sur une entité sud-coréenne
mais ça pourrait être là pour le coup je
précise aussi je ne vise pas
spécialement ce pays mais ça peut
apporter des conséquences graves est-ce
que en même temps ça peut être aussi le
symptôme d'une impuissance des pouvoirs
publics là ça serait aussi intéressant
d'avoir votre diagnostic si je puis dire
là-dessus et puis une petite question
subsidiaire mais elle est vraiment c'est
sur les effets des ruptures sur les
soignants vous avez apporté plein
d'éléments etc mais il y a une chose qui
nous qui a été évoquée lors d'audition
précédente on nous a parlé comme aux
États-Unis
mais ça a été écarté par exemple en
Suisse l'extension des dates de
péremption sur les médicaments est-ce
que vous c'est quelque chose au niveau
de vos associations que vous avez
abordées est-ce que ça pourrait être une
solution alors c'est j'ai dit c'est une
question subsidiaire parce que c'est pas
un c'est plus FA ctorielle etc mais
est-ce que ça peut être une une solution
je vous remercie Emma remarque sur les
maladies rares c'est que je me dis aussi
que les choses qui peuvent en déboucher
pour permettre aux patients d'être
effectivement soignés ça pourrait être
généralisé après à l'ensemble des
traitements
donc on va on va reprendre dans le dans
le même ordre les interventions
je vous laisse madame Simonin oui merci
alors je précise super rapide parce
qu'on a les questions d'actualité juste
derrière à 15h je suis vraiment désolé
mais on prendra en compte vos
contributions complémentaires merci
alors évidemment nous déplorons que la
révision législative de l'Union
européenne au niveau de ce qui était
prévu soit bloqué c'est évident ensuite
nous participons au groupe de travail
sur les pénuries au niveau européen
il y a par contre des des critères qui
notamment sur la liste des médicaments
qui sont des médicaments essentiels et
pas forcément sur la définition de
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur nous participons au niveau
européen sur cette commission
et ensuite la sécurité
d'approvisionnement pour l'instant il ne
parle pas de faire des stocks au niveau
européen donc c'est ce que nous
regrettons et rien non plus sur des une
fonction éventuelles vis-à-vis des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques ça c'est un
point je vous développera ces points là
par écrit ensuite je voudrais préciser
sur l'innovation est-elle un progrès
effectivement on voit bien qu'avec les
accès précoces sur la deuxième question
je peux répondre également donc sur les
accès précoces parfois ils ne sont pas
confirmés par l'évaluation par manque de
données nous avons des AMM qui sont
donnés sur des données très précoces
avec un degré d'incertitude important ce
sont pour des patients qui sont en bout
de ligne par exemple en oncologie et qui
n'ont pas d'autres alternatives
thérapeutiques donc on prévient le
patient on l'informe on lui fait une
notice d'information avant de lui
prescrire ce médicament qui est à
délivrance hospitalières et après dans
l'évaluation à la HAS j'y représente les
patients également et bien on regarde
justement par rapport à ces données si
on peut le comparer pour donner une
amélioration du service médical rendu et
là elle est nulle donc puisque on n'a
pas de comparateur établi et donc on
donne une asmr 5 ce qui bloque la
distribution du 10 médicaments en France
puisqu'ils ne sont pas éligibles à la
distension alors que ce sont des
médicaments comme ils sont innovants qui
sont chers et le retrait des
laboratoires ou du marché français où le
refus des prix qui sont proposés et le
refus des éligibilités à la distension
un problème d'équité d'accès sur le
territoire parce que si c'est asmr5
c'est une négociation qui se fait
directement avec les établissements de
santé et c'est très inéquitable regarde
la situation financière des
établissements dans les territoires je
vous remercie merci beaucoup de cet
élément éclairant madame
je veux pas déformer verras
je voulais pas le déformer
sur les enjeux enfin notre travail
auprès de l'Office européen des brevets
effectivement nous avons 5 expériences
nous avons déposé deux oppositions au
brevet à de brevets du sauce bovir et un
sur le kimrijah qui est un traitement
contre contre le cancer un quarté et
également deux observations de tiers qui
viennent donc avant que le brevet il
soit pris sur les vaccins covid-19 de
bientech et ce qu'on a constaté
effectivement dans notre notre par notre
expérience et que effectivement déjà il
y a donc dans les demandes des
industriels une large une large spectre
de demande beaucoup de demandes autour
d'un même produit donc et donc comme il
brevette toute la chaîne enfin tout ce
qui est possible effectivement il y a
des critères de loi donc l'activité
inventive et un des critères de
brevetabilité avec la nouveauté et
l'application industrielle et c'est une
fiction juridique en fait qui peut-être
interprété de façon plus large ou plus
restrictive donc ce qui s'est passé au
niveau européen dans les dans 2019 je
peux confirmer un rapport a été publié
justement pour influencer donc les
princes pour parler de la concurrence et
l'importance de la concurrence dans le
marché pharmaceutique européen en Europe
et ce rapport avait notamment influencé
un projet au sein de l'Office européen
de brevet qui s'appelle rising the bar
et l'idée était justement de rendre plus
rigoureux les critères de webtablit
l'interprétation des examinateurs et
apparemment ce projet il a été abandonné
et donc il n'y a pas effectivement une
obligation de redevabilité par rapport à
l'interprétation des examinateurs autour
des produits de santé donc voilà disons
que la notion d'activité inventive elle
justement elles permettent cette voilà
cette interprétation ou c'est de la
fiction juridique et elle peut elle a
donné sujet à l'occurrence il y a eu
plusieurs travaux notamment du d'un
juriste qui a travaillé pour l'ONU
justement sur la sur les critères de
revitabilité
dans une dimension de santé publique
donc qu'est-ce que ce serait donc par
exemple les combinaisons c'est déjà dans
l'état de la technique les combinaisons
de molécules donc il y a une série de
voilà de connaissances qui sont déjà
dans l'état de l'art et qui nous mettent
pas un brevet comme les polymorphes par
exemple etc par rapport à ce que vous
avez dit j'espère vous avoir vous vous
donnez des pistes par rapport
à l'impact des prix sur les
rationnements donc c'est ce que nous
avions vu avec le Sophus bovir au sein
de nos programmes parce que nous
travaillons donc avec les usagers les
usagers de drogue et c'est une
population effectivement qui avait
besoin de ce traitement là très touché
par l'hépatite C
après nous avons commencé à travailler
sur l'impact sur le système de santé
parce que disons que le rationnement
d'aujourd'hui ou l'accès aujourd'hui ça
implique également voilà un impact sur
l'ensemble du système et l'accès aux
soins et le système de santé le prix des
médicaments et le système de santé ne
sont pas décorrélés donc nous voulions
mettre ça en perspective et donc la
licence d'office donc on soutient que
c'est effectivement un outil pour mettre
en place des génériques elle a été
utilisée dans plusieurs pays et voilà
elle a été très utile pour justement
faire des économies sur plusieurs
médicaments dans le cas du sophisme elle
aurait dû elle a toujours on est
toujours dans des conditions où il
pourrait être mobilisées parce que le
Sophus bovir est un tel traitement qui
continue on continue à payer le prix de
monopole même si le prix a baissé et
voilà beaucoup a été rapporté notamment
par le Sénat par différents acteurs sur
le modèle économique de l'entreprise et
comment il y a eu il y a des abus dans
ce modèle économique donc voilà et
finalement et voilà et c'est tout
madame allemand souriez s'il vous plaît
oui alors vous nous avez posé la
question donc à l'échelle européenne
très rapidement
donc ah pardon
concernant la coordination à l'échelle
européenne bien sûr que c'est une
problématique qui est importante on en a
vraiment besoin d'harmoniser les
étiquetages le marché avec des prix qui
sont régulés afin que les pays de
l'Union européenne se passent pas
concurrence entre eux et il faut aussi
fluidifier le marché du médicament les
ventes de médicaments au sein de l'Union
pour que un pays puisse venir en aide à
un autre et ça ça passera que par des
harmonisations d'étiquetage et une
harmonisation entre différents marchés
européens donc bien sûr que que c'est
que c'est important comme sujet vous
aviez posé la question aussi également
de la des soignants donc de donc on
aille boire aborder l'effet des ruptures
sur les soignants et les et les patients
et donc l'extension des dates de
péremption donc pour ça c'est un c'est
une piste qui est intéressante mais pour
ça il nous faut des études de stabilité
sur les principes actifs et pourquoi pas
s'appuyer sur le travail des eaux
médites puisque je vous rappelle que les
homédies existent à l'échelle
territorial c'est des structures sur
lesquelles on s'appuie peu qui sont
financés qui manquent par contre de
moyens logistiques et qui arrivent à
élaborer des gadlines assez pertinents
sur sur les sur les sur les médicaments
et qui nous sont nous les cliniciens les
praticiens assez utiles donc s'appuyer
sur sur des structures telles que les
eaux médites qui dépendent des ARS sur
le plan territorial pour études
d'ailleurs ils ont ils publient des
études de stabilité pour les pour les
perfusions à domicile etc donc on peut
leur poser la question et ils pourront
aider les praticiens donc à envisager
ces ruptures de façon
plus plus harmonieuse et plus et plus
facile donc pour les pour les ruptures
donc on a on a des outils aussi qui dont
on a besoin sur le terrain c'est
l'outils dépéruptures qui doit être
aussi étendue qui est utilisée par les
pharmaciens et qui doit être étendu au
prescripteurs parce que comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure on a besoin
d'outil de communication sur le terrain
on a besoin de coordination on a besoin
de pilotage on a besoin voilà de de
c'est un problème de gouvernance donc
sur le terrain pour les pour les
soignants en effet besoin d'aide on a
besoin
de que la gouvernance nous aide pour
piloter tout ça et par rapport au prix
de l'innovation moi je j'ai plutôt
l'impression que l'innovation est payée
et bien rentabilisée par le par les
budgets publics puisque on a quand même
un gros budget qui a loué à l'innovation
et je me demande si l'innovation n'est
pas payée justement par un prix trop bas
des médicaments essentiels et des prix
un prix trop bas des médicaments matures
donc c'est tous l'équilibre à trouver
dans l'avenir pour ces pour ces
médicaments je vous remercie
monsieur prouet
sur la question de l'impuissance des
pouvoirs publics
sur la puissance des pouvoirs publics en
disant que finalement sa véritable bras
de fer se souvient de Paul Hudson donc
le PDG de Sanofi qui en mars 2020 après
avoir reçu 280 millions d'euros du
gouvernement américain et vu l'action de
sadofi monter 10% disait que si le
gouvernement français ne faisait pas la
même chose et bien il serait privé des
premiers vaccins donc ça véritable bras
de fer dans lequel je pense le
gouvernement refuse d'utiliser les
instruments qui sont à sa disposition il
s'agit pas d'une impuissance naturelle
et qui tomberait du sel je prends
quelques éléments crédit d'impôts
recherche pour Sanofi c'est près de 7
milliards d'euros qui ont été donnés en
une dizaine d'années dans le même temps
crédit impôt recherche ça nos filles
licencier 5000 chercheurs et basculer sa
recherche vers les États-Unis autre
élément qui aurait pu être utilisé c'est
le gouvernement qui après un vote sur
les stocks de 4 mois publié à degrés sur
des stocks de deux mois c'est aussi la
possibilité de mobiliser l'article 31 31
15 du code de la santé publique qui
permet dans le cadre de l'urgence
de réquisitionner certains produits ou
certaines productions une mesure que le
gouvernement a toujours refusé
d'appliquer je prends l'exemple du
Sauval dit dans le même temps ou en
France ont payé l'autorisation
temporaire d'utilisation à 75000 euros
c'est redescendu à 45 au début
maintenant je crois que c'est 24000
euros le traitement de 3 mois un pays
comme l'Égypte qui refaisait refusait la
brevetteilité permettait de traiter pour
à peu près 300 euros le traitement de
trois mois
25000 euros 300 euros
1,4 millions de personnes en Égypte et
favorisaient même le tourisme médical en
faisant vanter par des influenceurs
voilà donc il y a tout à fait les moyens
et puis il y avait le moyen la bombe
atomique au moment de du covid c'était
que le gouvernement français se décide à
l'OMC à ce que c'est représentant lève
les brevets
pour permettre à l'humanité d'avoir dans
tous ces segments et dans tous ces
secteurs donc plutôt que une impuissance
naturelle face à une force qui elle-même
serait naturelle on a une impuissance
organisée parce que et en France on le
sait plus qu'ailleurs l'exemple de
Servier le montre il y a des connivences
fortes depuis des décennies entre les
pouvoirs publics et les petits
laboratoires qui grâce à ses liens
politiques sont devenus des mastodontes
à l'international et ça aussi c'est un
sujet dont il faudra un jour parler
très bien monsieur Duguet donc très
rapidement trois points qui ont été
soulevés le premier c'est sur la
question du rationnement sur les
médicaments et innovants oui ce
rationnement aujourd'hui il existe mais
il existe où ces médicaments innovants
pour l'essentiel sont des médicaments
qui sont prescrits à l'hôpital or
aujourd'hui avec la faillite de
l'hôpital et bien les équipes
hospitalières se retrouvent dans
l'incapacité de pouvoir donner dans des
délaiss corrects les rendez-vous qui
sont nécessaires tout simplement pour
mettre en traitement et suivre ces
traitements de ces patients on a
amélioré là depuis des ans très
fortement grâce à l'évolution de la loi
le dispositif d'accès compassionnel
d'accès précoce réglement ça marche mais
on a oublié que si on mettait pas les
moyens nécessaires quand un traitement
arrivait pour que à l'hôpital et puisse
avoir les moyens d'évaluer de coordonner
de mettre dans les bases de données etc
et bien ça bloque là et on se retrouve
avec des situations le médicament il
autorisé il est remboursable mais
l'équipe hospitalière est obligé de dire
bah excusez-moi ma pauvre dame j'ai pas
de rendez-vous avant six mois pour vous
mettre sous traitement voilà voilà la
réalité d'aujourd'hui donc déjà oui ce
rationnement existe et oui pour les
traitements innovants lorsqu'ils
arrivent il faut identifier aussi tous
les moyens qui sont nécessaires à
l'hôpital pour qu'il puisse être
prescrit et pour qu'on puisse suivre
toutes les données notamment qui veulent
qui veulent être collectés on dit il
faut faire plein de données en vie
réelle et on a pas un dispositif
satisfaisant pour pouvoir financer leurs
collègues deuxième point que vous avez
évoqué qui est celui sur la question de
l'indépendance sanitaire à l'automne
2019 nous avons en tant qu'afm organisé
à l'Assemblée nationale un colloque qui
était intitulé thérapie génique et
indépendance sanitaire de la France je
dois vous dire que à l'automne 2019
lorsqu'on leur parlait d'indépendance
sanitaire de la France beaucoup de
personnes et beaucoup d'élus nous
souriait au nez on avait l'impression
que ce que l'on racontait c'était
quelque chose qui était en dehors du
temps lorsqu'on en disait attention
attention on est là sur un enjeu qui est
un enjeu majeur et où on disait aussi
les thérapies géniques c'est une
révolution médicale qui est de nature à
pouvoir changer de façon durable à façon
de soigner plein de maladies qui est
jusqu'à présent ne pouvait pas le l'être
et il faut absolument que la France qui
a une historiquement une recherche
académique de premier niveau mondial qui
a été la pionnière surtout ces sujets
puissent ne pas rater
l'industrialisation de tous ces produits
et que on ne soit pas dans les
situations où les inventions le début se
fait dans les équipes en France et où
l'industrialisation les profits et le
retour à très gros a appris des mesurés
viennent de laboratoire essentiellement
nord-américain est-ce qu'on a été écouté
depuis non insuffisamment il est urgent
il est important de pouvoir en France
investir massivement pour avoir une
vraie filière dédiée au ginothérapie une
filière ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que il y a besoin pour produire ces
produits qui sont excessivement
complexes d'énormément d'acteurs qui
soient sur un même territoire pour
coordonner leurs efforts pour notamment
réussir à le relever le défi qui est de
diviser par 100 les coûts de production
puisque c'est ça aujourd'hui qui bloque
et pour ça il faut avoir un ensemble
d'acteurs alors vous avez cité
hyposcasique est effectivement une
plateforme de production que nous avions
créé quand elle a été créée c'était la
plus grosse au monde sauf que le monde
évolue très vite et que depuis quelques
années si vous regardez ce qui se passe
sur les thérapies géniques les
investissements en usine de production
c'est des 500 millions par ci un
milliard par là qui se font dans le
monde entier hyposcasie avait besoin
pour son développement de trouver des
fonds suffisamment importants qui n'ont
pas été possible à notre grande
désespoir de trouver en France ou en
Europe mais aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
quoi c'est que c'est fond permettent de
garantir que le développement et les
productions d'hyposkaisie se fassent en
France se fasse à Évry et là une
nouvelle usine qui permet d'augmenter
très fortement la capacité de production
est en train de se finir et va ouvrir
avec de l'emploi en France et avec un
acteur qui reste un acteur qui dans
l'écosystème doit pouvoir jouer un rôle
important et nous appelons fortement de
nos vœux que dans le cadre des appels
d'offres lancés par le gouvernement pour
des bioclusteurs de niveau international
se développe en France et bien qu'il y
ait bien un biocluster dédié au
génothérapie et il y a un projet qui est
porté qui est un projet ambitieux parce
que en faisant de cette façon là
peut-être que le gouvernement pourrait
montrer que il a été compris que l'enjeu
d'instruisternalisation de ces produits
en France est important et puis dernier
point très rapidement et là il est très
rapide vous avez dit les maladies rares
modèles pour les maladies fréquentes
c'est ce qu'on a dit pendant longtemps
et là ce que je vous disais qui est
nouveau et qu'on observe c'est que on
est à la limite oui on a pris le modèle
oui on a investi dans un premier temps
pour les maladies les plus rares et
maintenant on va vers les maladies les
plus fréquentes et on laisse tomber les
maladies les plus rares d'où l'important
c'est pour ça que j'insistais tout à
l'heure de créer un fond qui puisse
permettre de continuer un fonds publics
d'innovation pour que pour ces maladies
ne soient pas les indones de la farce en
ayant servi de terrain d'entraînement
pour les maladies les plus fréquentes et
qu'elles se retrouvent aujourd'hui de
nouveau sans perspective thérapeutique
et bien merci beaucoup je vous prie de
m'excuser de vous avez été très bavard
au début c'est vous qui avez mangé votre
temps donc mes collègues je leur
proposerai de nous fournir un certain
nombre de questions qu'on vous enverra
en même temps parce que c'est une grosse
frustration pour pour tout le monde et
puis
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer toutes les
contributions que vous souhaitez nous
faire parvenir et sont toutes
lu et analysé avec attention il y a le
serviront
utilement le le rapport final
voilà qui sera donc rendu mi-juillet
suivant le calendrier prévu et donc je
vous remercie et je vous salue je vous
salue aussi madame en distance voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs ici